Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Vi ricordate 30 anni fa,
i film di fantascienza?
Io non ero ancora nata,
eppure si immaginavano mondi
popolati da auto volanti e robot.
Ad oggi non abbiamo ancora
progettato le auto volanti,
eppure abbiamo inventato
qualcosa di ancora più fenomenale:
i droni.
Se ci pensate bene,
un drone non è nient'altro
che un robot volante.
Semplici, piccoli e leggeri,
decisamente meno costosi
di qualsiasi prototipo di robot.
Maneggevoli, grazie
a quattro semplici eliche
che permettono di spostarsi
in diverse direzioni:
in alto o in basso, a destra a sinistra;
ma soprattutto sicuri,
perché utilizzano
sensori anti-collisione e radar
per evitare qualsiasi tipo di ostacolo.
La configurazione dei droni
li rende una tecnologia
estremamente duttile e versatile.
Ed è proprio per questo motivo
che un anno fa ho deciso di impiegarli
all'interno della mia azienda.
Per voi i droni potranno essere
nient'altro che un mero strumento,
ma per me hanno rappresentato
un vero e proprio risveglio.
Ed è grazie alle potenzialità dei droni
che intendo, insieme ai miei soci,
plasmare un futuro nuovo,
innovativo e prosperoso
dove la tradizione e la tecnologia,
la governance e le imprese
possano lavorare assieme
per risvegliare la coscienza collettiva
e assicurare un futuro migliore
ai nostri figli.
Ora vi starete chiedendo, innanzitutto,
chi non vorrebbe assicurare
un futuro migliore ai propri figli
e inoltre che cosa diamine
c'entrano i droni con tutto questo.
Bene, se la risposta
alla prima domanda è scontata,
quella alla seconda
è decisamente più complessa
ed è per questo motivo che sono qui oggi,
per mostrarvi che i droni
non sono relegati al nostro immaginario,
ma sono una realtà concreta.
Sono già impiegati in diversi settori,
e lo saranno sempre di più:
gli usi sono innumerevoli,
dai più banali ai più complessi.
Ora, nell'immaginario comune
il drone è uno strumento di guerra
utilizzato per operazioni
di ricognizione e sorveglianza.
Tuttavia questo non vuol dire
che possa essere utilizzato
per cause ben più nobili:
dalla banale ricerca
e soccorso di dispersi
in caso di disastri naturali
come slavine e terremoti,
al trasporto di organi da trapianto
in località remote
e difficilmente accessibili.
Voglio darvi un esempio concreto
delle potenzialità che queste piccole
macchine volanti hanno.
Partiamo dall'inizio,
dal problema: le api.
Esse sono responsabili,
per il 75 percento,
dell'impollinazione
delle colture del mondo.
Parliamo di mele, ciliegie,
broccoli, mirtilli.
Ora, a causa del cambiamento climatico
e del crescente uso di pesticidi,
la popolazione delle api
sta diminuendo drasticamente
e ad essere colpiti
non saranno solo gli alimenti
che vi ho appena citato,
ma anche gli erbivori
che producono latticini e carne;
la canola,
che è utilizzata come biocarburante
in molti paesi in via di sviluppo;
e addirittura il cotone
di cui sono fatti i vostri vestiti.
Come potete ben vedere,
questi dati sono estremamente allarmanti
e nonostante la cattiva notizia
che non ci siano previsioni
di invertire questo trend,
alcuni scienziati hanno inventato
un mini drone capace
di impollinare i fiori
e così supplire al declino delle api.
Utilizzando delle semplici
crini di cavallo,
che vanno a riprodurre il pelo delle api,
e un gel che cattura il polline,
questi mini droni possono garantire
la sicurezza alimentare
in un futuro così incerto.
Ovviamente,
questo non è un buon motivo
per far morire le api!
Ora questo è solo uno
degli innumerevoli esempi
delle potenzialità dei droni.
Presto entreranno a far parte
delle vostre vite a 360 gradi,
a partire dalla frutta
e della verdura che mettete in tavola.
I droni possono essere impiegati
per controllare la maturazione dei frutti,
per spargere pesticidi in modo localizzato
o addirittura per diffondere la semente.
Senza dimenticare che diventeranno
le nuove auto del futuro,
e rivoluzioneranno completamente
le facce della nostra città,
soprattutto per quanto riguarda
il trasporto di pacchi,
via aerea anziché su ruote.
Il vostro postino di fiducia
sarà un drone.
Li vedrete al mare
quando sarete in vacanza,
perché i guardaspiaggia li utilizzeranno
per controllare i bagnanti
e per trasportare i salvagente
in caso di emergenza.
O semplicemente li utilizzeranno
per l'intrattenimento:
questi sono 2018 droni utilizzati da Intel
per comporre uno spettacolo di luci.
[Video]
Molti obiettori insistono sul rischio
che queste nuove tecnologie comportano
per quanto riguarda
il rispetto della privacy.
Eppure, ciò non è dovuto ai droni.
La perdita della privacy
va imputata alla curiosità
e alla voglia che abbiamo
di condividere ciò che ci piace,
ciò che non ci piace,
dove abitiamo, le nostre abitudini,
con gli altri.
Semplicemente non c'è bisogno
di un drone o di una telecamera
per spiare cosa fate
la sera nelle vostre case,
o cosa avete mangiato a pranzo,
perché probabilmente
l'avrete già condiviso sui social network.
Il vero problema è legato
alla mancanza di norme e regole.
Non importa quanto avanzata
sia la tecnologia dei vostri droni,
questi non andranno mai
a sostituire l'uomo.
Sì, sono delle macchine che servono
a renderci la vita più facile,
ma sono pur sempre
delle macchine controllate dall'uomo.
Ora la questione
non riguarda solo i droni,
ma le nuove tecnologie in generale.
C'è bisogno che le istituzioni
ne regolamentino l'utilizzo al più presto
e che lavorino assieme alle imprese
e agli enti locali,
al fine di delineare un piano d'azione
conciso ma completo,
che possa superare gli ostacoli
di una burocrazia spesso oberante
e responsabile del soffocamento
di innumerevoli iniziative.
E non solo queste iniziative
non sono promosse dai governi,
ma sono spesso ostacolate
dalla lentezza dell'apparato burocratico.
Un esempio eclatante si tratta
della Corporate Social Responsibility,
o la cosiddetta responsabilità
sociale d'impresa,
è la voglia delle grandi,
e piccole e medie imprese,
di avere un impatto sociale positivo
sulla comunità circostante.
Si tratta di utilizzare
una piccola parte dei propri profitti
al fine di contribuire
a preservare il nostro pianeta,
senza il quale non potremmo sopravvivere.
In giro per il mondo ci sono
innumerevoli esempi di aziende
che utilizzano propri droni
per combattere le grandi sfide
di questo secolo.
Ad esempio il cambiamento climatico.
In California si utilizzano
fotocamere termiche montate sui droni
così da contenere gli incendi
che ogni estate
bruciano sempre più ettari.
In Kenya e in Tanzania
i droni vengono impiegati
per salvaguardare la flora e la fauna
e prevenire attività di bracconaggio;
mentre in Myanmar sono utilizzati
per diffondere la semente
per riforestare le zone costiere
abitate da mangrovie.
Ed è proprio di "Corporate Social
Responsibility" che mi occupo
all'interno dell'azienda
che ho fondato un anno fa,
ad appena 18 anni, in Silicon Valley,
con mio fratello che, diciamo,
mi ha cresciuto a pane e droni.
Utilizziamo un servizio, una rete,
un network di piloti di droni
per fornire servizi di sicurezza;
ma la parte più interessante
è l'idea di un modello di sviluppo
che unisca assieme il business
e la responsabilità civile.
Così, in caso di emergenza,
possiamo offrire il nostro aiuto
alla comunità che ci ha accolti
e senza la quale non potremmo esistere.
Eppure, purtroppo,
la lentezza dell'apparato burocratico
e la mancanza di norme ci rallenta,
e spesso ci impedisce
di intervenire in modo tempestivo.
Ed è proprio per questo motivo
che le istituzioni devono guidare
il processo di rinnovamento tecnologico.
Con appena 19 anni sulle spalle,
sono forse ancora
troppo idealista e ottimista
all'idea di poter cambiare
e contribuire al cambiamento necessario
per garantire un futuro ai miei figli.
Ho tutta la vita davanti,
eppure sento l'impellenza
di agire, di tentare
perché ho la speranza
che la mia generazione possa, e debba,
invertire il trend negativo
che ormai stiamo seguendo da troppo tempo.
È arrivato il momento del risveglio,
e non stiamo parlando
di un risveglio tecnologico o economico.
Parliamo di un risveglio
della coscienza collettiva
e della classe dirigente.
From the bottom to the top,
al fine di lavorare assieme
per dare inizio a un nuovo Rinascimento,
alla scoperta e alla salvaguardia
della bellezza del nostro pianeta.
(Applausi)